la rumeur de la semaine le père de
beyoncé s'apprête à tout révéler sur la
superstar dans un biopic alors ça c'est
assez hallucinant c'est voilà c'est
c'est donc le break comme jeudi 2-2 de
beyoncé qui a des heures et des heures
dit miller de roche ou sur sa fille et
que beaucoup moins dix mille heures de
rushes vous aider et qui veut donc tout
sortir tout déballer et raconter un peu
comme les biblique sur les soeurs
williams avec le père comme le père a
fait en sorte les deux soeurs du bien
des reines du tennis mais bella va
raconter comment bionz est devenue la
reine de la chanson elle elle est fâchée
avec son père visiblement elle est pas
contente de ça alors est ce que ça vous
choque ou pas qui sorte qu'ils sortent
pas valable petit peu toute l'histoire
sur bien de fait ou pas oui et non oui
ça vous choque pas je suis choqué je
suis outré mais bon c'est un sale type
mathieu noir mathew knowles comment vous
dire ça fait quelques années qu'il a
commencé une campagne un peu pour
dénigrer sa fille en disant si elle un
succès planétaire c'est parce qu'elle a
la peau claire et aux états unis l'elite
skins et les dark skin ya un petit peu
une petite guéguerre déjà il dit ça il
dit que bien on sait il va cracher sur
sur ses plus grosses fêlures ne fait qu
elle sache pas trop s'exprimer en public
ils racontent plein de d'atrocités
concernant beyoncé qui lui en veut par
rapport à auffay calais qu'il ait mis la
main dans la caisse comme le père de
whitney houston à l'époque c'est pour ça
qu'ils se sont séparés c'est parce qu'il
lui a volé de l'oseille en fait de lui
ce qu'il est aussi serré que sans lui
mais si elle ne serait pas du web lancé
et qui sait donner à boukamal est
qu'aujourd'hui ne récolte pas les fruits
n'est que avec les pats généreux et non
comme joe jackson comme tous ceux qui
ont fait des enfants stars mais il il a
volé de l'argent et ils sortent jusqu'à
maintenant sur le succès de beyoncé de
solange qu'est-ce qui vient de casser
les lélés les burnes
faut quand même rappeler qu'il était le
manager donc des destiny's child way we
de beyoncé nos leçons que c'est même
très important il a des choses à dire la
société qui produisait les cinémas etc a
été la sienne est aujourd'hui le projet
qui veut mettre en avant c'est aussi sa
carrière à lui dire qu'il existe en tant
que même élu en tant que lui oui mais
ils vont jouer mais c'est à dire que ce
sera pas que sa fille y aura aussi lui
qui sera partie prenante et pisciculture
sa fictivement les dix meilleurs je suis
légalement et techniquement il a le
droit il ya quelque chose de d'usurper
sait il a le droit de le faire mais moi
je suis partagé en fait
parce que mettons le temps on a très
envie de le voir parce que voir un peu
l'évolution du billet qui est quand même
pour moi la star la plus extraordinaire
de notre génération ça me ça m'excite un
peu jaloux non c'est important je pense
d'eux de se dire c'est que bien de ses
en effet elle n'a été fait grâce à
elle-même surtout parce qu'une voix un
talent comme ça même voulons géniteur je
peux même s'il a aidé à démarrer si
beyoncé c'est la quinny d'accord c'est
la queen là on sent que là c'est
l'expertisé la queen
will tear whitney houston il n'a pas eu
depuis les voir surtout que bien de ses
n'a pas pris le relais de whitney
houston non non
non sinon ces noms vous ambiancer elle
est là maintenant elle est là en termes
de volonté et tout
beyoncé on a plus qu'un navet vous tenez
vous bien sûr alors à des animaux parce
qu'après le marbre ans passés aux côtés
important et un jour le sujet voilà mais
ça nous ramène au sujet précédent le
fait que les américains sont des biopics
sur tous donc oui absolument le petit
souci aussi avec le père de beyoncé sait
qu'il n'a pas du tout sa langue dans sa
poche c'est qu'il a l'habitude un peu de
jacter en petit à l'époque en l'étant
dispute avec non mais c'est vrai qu'on
était en dispute avec djezzy lui avait
été racontée à tout moment mais les gars
vous savez il ya une tournée qui se
prépare il faut qu'ils vendent des
billets etc donc ils vont faire semblant
de s'embrouiller un peu mais vous
inquiétez pas ils sont trés toujours
amoureux et c'est donc il a tout il n'a
pas l'habitude de parler de parler de
parler consolante a mis sous lens qui
est la seule c'est bien le samu une
énorme gifle à djezzy dans l'ascenseur
c'est même elle lui a mis des patates
lui c'est pas du tout gêné après pour en
parler et dire non mais solange à est
complètement ouf d'abord on avait vidé
au total à gifles et après on passera à
madonna vous allez voir aussi à la wii
incroyable quand même elle l'avait
fracasse
incroyable